what's up y'all we have the Samsung s23
in the office and it is the newest
device from Samsung and one of the most
powerful Android devices in the market
how good is it that's what we want to
know and we are going to put it through
the gauntlet we're going to be playing
the engine impact pubg mobile called
mobile and Diablo Immortal and find out
how much this beautiful phone can handle
in a single run the sne3 that we have
runs a Snapdragon 8 Gen 2 for its
chipset and in journal 740 for its GPU 8
gigs of RAM a 5 000 milliamp hour
battery and all of it plays out on a
magnificent Dynamic AMOLED 120hz screen
and before we run the the test let's do
a baseline of the temperatures on the
front and the back of the phone to start
things off already at 29 degrees 29.4
basically everything's just below 30
degrees on the front very nice back but
it's kind of getting warm down here
29 29 29 29
yeah everything's basically just below
30 degrees Celsius all right so
currently we are at 97 battery and let's
just kick things off by playing Genji
impact all right so the first thing you
notice is that the speakers actually on
the side of the phone right here and I
believe there are no other speaker Parts
on either side except for here so when
you guys are playing you know you guys
will accidentally cover the speakers
like this but for the purpose of this
playthrough I'm going to try and keep my
hands out as open as possible so let's
just get in
okay looks like we're in Monster right
now and let's just open up the settings
real quick
graphics and okay let's go to the
highest still overclocked and let's see
high high uh fps to 60.
and everything else will be turned on
all right all right so with that look
his hair looks great and after that all
the details on the top you can see oh
you can see the reflections on this
button on here it's oh this looks really
great
and let's see how animation works out
so far pretty smooth
all right so let's get into some light
and as you can see Shadows are looking
pretty good the particles on the water
is actually pretty smooth I haven't seen
any like raindrops whatsoever all right
so with that let's move in Azuma and see
how the phone can handle a larger area
with a lot more characters and NPCs
Uma city all right let's fast travel
all right
okay we need a zoom right now and
whoa damn
this looks really good oh
all right let's get Back Up
let's see Statue looks great and
so far no Family Jokes but we haven't
entered an area with a lot of NPCs yet
so let's just move in
and look at the Sun how it crests Over
the Horizon
[Music]
right so let's move on to the city and
so far even though we're running for the
city with a lot of NPCs this one is
handling itself pretty damn well
let's go to the end
the speaker's actually doing great even
though it's a single speaker on the side
I'm not exactly sure where else the
other outputs are from but this is
actually pretty good on its own and with
that let's actually go into a combat
encounter
so exploring outside so far it is pretty
good lighting's great running distance
is pretty far off as you can see and oh
this looks really good it feels really
good to play with it but I'll say that
it's getting a bit warm at the back so
let's just check that real quick
yeah it's even though like almost 40
degrees on the back almost 40 I'd say
but yeah it's not uncomfortable in any
kind of way so let's just keep playing
and get into a combating counter
okay I see some UPS over there
I believe
okay let's get into a fight right about
no
nice
goodbye
oh someone up there smart actually
[Music]
nice
[Applause]
right now
it's pretty smooth I don't see oh
he's down okay great but yeah
combination so far pretty smooth and
let's just get in kill this last guy
[Applause]
oh
I mean right
oh he's still up
all right with all them down that was
actually pretty smooth and pretty slick
I mean I could have done better with
that look but yeah
exploring getting the compound Outdoors
is still a pretty smooth experience I
haven't seen any drastic frame rate
drops so let's move on to the abyss okay
so with the abyss obviously you know the
more mops in an indoor setting so we'll
see how the phone can handle that and
let's get into it
special attacks and everything no
firmware drops whatsoever I mean
obviously everything is pretty squishy
squishy so pretty easy deckings
again you will find yourself covering
this because quite a fair bit too
[Applause]
this guy and we're done right so let's
get to the impact we were at 97 battery
now we're at 90 battery so it's actually
not too bad handling all the graphical
settings that Genji is throwing at it
this thing is a b so far so let's do a
final temperature check real quick
and on the front it's still at around 37
percent
for the day in the life of the traveler
at the front it's still about 38 degrees
Celsius it's still pretty hot on the
front
40 degrees celsius not much of a
difference but you can feel it when
you're playing with it other than the
temperature throughout the s23 is
handling the game to the game well all
right so let's move on to the next game
pubg mobile okay so before we get into
pubg mobile let's just check the
temperatures real quick on the back
I'll be hitting on 31 degrees 30 degrees
or heat dissipates pretty fast in this
thing so let's check the front
oh never mind 32 32 32 all right and
we're doing pretty all right that's a
baseline for pubg mobile and let's just
get into the game okay so now that we're
here let's go into the settings real
quick
so Ultra HD because you can't go USD yet
it's still not available
so this is a nice big screen on here
it's actually quite easy to get around
the UI you got a little bit of frame
rate drops here and there it's not
exactly the smoothest but it's all right
probably there so far
because the characters look really good
as you can see the sun is hitting off a
jacket really nicely so let's see how it
fits in the game rendering arise the
C130 looks really good as you can see
like the lights Hitting off the plane
pretty well and also rendering off the
map also pretty good
here's the initially drop we're doing
pretty fine so far not exactly sure
where we're gonna go but it's a bit
choppy when it comes to the FPS I can't
really tell that we're hitting or like
40 FPS here we are we're gonna land on
severely right now so far it's been
pretty smooth as you can see the
textures all the buildings around us are
loading up pretty nicely and let's wait
for the drop
should be doing good let's just not fold
that guy and just get into the store
real quick and pick out some items
off so in three two
one
so far everything's pretty smooth the
textures are all loading up pretty
nicely and smoothly I'd say
all right let's just get down there
posting first order of the day yeah but
it's out of this this is to obviously
get a weapon and not to get whatever
equipment and
accessories we can find so let's just
get in the
and oh crap there's a lot of people on
there
that's no more children issue let's just
get into this house over here
like you're off
get in there real quick I think someone
just landed near me
come on okay grab that site
weapon open weapon
so so far controls and everything feel
really smooth it's all good for now yeah
oh yeah okay that was oh Jesus Christ
where's the guy
that was cool what is up with this
little crap
okay I am really low right now
okay I'll teammates mopping up the
silver right now so that's great
and I really can't find anyone to kill
so
so far the snapdrug is handling pubg
pretty well and let's just say that oh
F16 let's do that
okay
where's the guy oh okay they're building
over there it's pretty far off
we are still in the clear
oh he's not in the building over there
oh
yeah let's give somebody safe I'm gonna
die
and I did before I get into the next
part let's just do a quick temperature
check mid session we are at 34-ish
degrees honestly it's a big Improvement
compared to Genji just now which was
running at like 40 or even like 39 so
this is actually pretty good
temperatures on the front
33 33 34
yeah I was actually doing pretty well
for this one obviously you know gianshin
is a high performing game compared to
about G but
yeah assistant pretty well I believe we
should be all right for now but judging
by how the performance is so far oh
that's funny that's not me find that
photo oh I'll see you
[Applause]
all right got him
down nice
no oh no
okay cool
let's get this stuff
so far in the game the s22 doesn't feel
hot at all honestly it's a lot more
comfortable to play with compared to
genjin by a smidgen because you know
it's not heating up the crazy amounts
let's just do a temperature check real
quick but yeah it's doing so much better
compared against you in fact we're just
running at what 39 40 degrees almost on
the front and the back
so let's check the chipset aerial quick
it sits up yeah okay I'm done all right
so currently we are at 82 down from 90
so that's eight percent throughout the
three games that we played I mean the
first two and five pretty fast but let's
check the temperatures on the front and
the back
[Applause]
[Music]
36 34. wow okay
again doing a lot better again because
you know it's not as demanding as
Kenshin
get back
yeah
it's being pretty fine wow right so with
pubg done let's move on to Call of Duty
mobile but before that here's a message
from our sponsor secretlab here at geek
culture we've tested plenty of chairs
but Secret Life gaming chairs remain one
of our favorites whether it's for work
or play they feel great to lean back
against with the ergonomic features
offering support for the whole body from
the head
and back
to the arms and even something for your
butt this mix of format function helps
the Titan Evo 2020 to deliver the best
seating experience like no other for
more information check out secretlab.co
all right so coming in from pubg we're
going to go into Call of Duty mobile but
before that we are currently at 82 and
let's just check the temperatures real
quick
we got 32.5 on the front heat dissipates
really quickly on this thing actually
and let's check the back 31 32 yeah
pretty much 32 ish across the board so
he dissipates on heat distributes pretty
well on the Samsung S3 so without
further Ado let's get into Call of Duty
mobile
all right so now we're gonna be menu the
major looks really good look at the sun
bouncing off her leather jacket there is
quite aside oh that looks really good
okay so let's move on to the settings
and check what's up Graphics uh very
high on the max for frame rate I mean
I'll put it on Ultra but I don't want
low Graphics so just keep it very high
and Max for frame rate
all right multiplayer everything is
turned on and with that let's just get
into a match models looking Pretty
stinking nice let's see the gun models
EDS looks really good
look at the details on the buttons here
oh this is looking pretty sick to see if
that is happening in the s23 so let's
just get in and start killing
oh let's dance move wow
[Applause]
sound is pretty sick on this thing I
mean we did tell the audio resource back
so that's why it's sounding really good
um
it's still pretty comfortable to play
with I mean this is a pretty large phone
but I have huge hands so this works out
for me
[Applause]
damn it oh yeah
give me you guys the game is getting
well no fury trucks whatsoever come on
come on come on come on come on
yeah
it's running pretty spooky especially
with this 120 hertz screen I wish you
guys were here to see this but oh
one down
[Applause]
all right change up
yeah I can't could not get in there and
come in with the buttons please win more
free firing
all right here we go
radio Enemy Inside
actually but yeah
let's just keep them contained here
very nice
oh everyone sick
I mean okay it's a relatively short game
but from what I can tell the S3 is doing
a pretty damn good job with how it
handles the graphical settings and how
beautiful everything is on the screen so
let's just check temperatures real quick
as you guys watch myself One Touch
[Applause]
there we go sick right temperature check
and with like this one game we are
currently at 80 then we took up two
percent so let's check the temperatures
on the front
all right 33 35 32 yeah not much of a
change from when you first started off I
think maybe it's about a degree or two
off
let's check the back real quick
so you want that you do yeah still the
same as the front
okay maybe a bit higher by like maybe
two degrees but other than that this
phone is handling it pretty damn well
right with that let's move on to the
next game on the last game Diablo
Immortal all right before Diablo
Immortal starts let's do a quick
temperature check and we are currently
at 79 battery I guess you guys saw it Go
number one percent earlier on all right
so let's just check temperatures real
quick we are at 29 degrees also down
here
all right on the front and at the back
31 inch and honestly real feel lights it
still feels pretty cool to the touch
so with that let's get into Diablo
Immortal all right so your cow food here
and she looks pretty good look at the
blood on the blade okay I believe you're
in
which means symmetry right now only the
castle let's just check most of the
stuff off before that let's go to
settings real quick
graphics and 60 FPS let's do that Ultra
resolution is not here yet so we're
going to stick to high image outputting
yeah why not
kind of push everything up everything's
on very high everything is turned on so
yeah sick let's keep going let's explore
this area it's a bit dark let me just
adjust that real quick
I believe this should be fine so we're
running at a solid 60 FPS and let's keep
moving it's really buttery smooth right
now and look at the amount of mops you
have you need to get into a fight
very nice
very much that's good
let's compete a dungeon
[Applause]
all right so we are one of the most
popular okay so we are one of the most
populated areas by NPCs and players in
West March and let's just check out
what's going on on here oh how many
people actually today that's nice for a
change and before that let's just get in
here let's enter the Elder Rift
for the uninitiatives basically just a
spiral of this but for Diablo model for
those kitchen players out there but
basically you guys get to go into the
dungeon and stop playing games so let's
just enter and start a rampage so you
have a click first
start sending everything on this ID
ol is out
oh boy
right now even with a lot of effects
going on right now it's actually
handling itself
very nice
just keep fighting and honestly I'd say
the sap is holding at 50 well with
Diablo motor and the highest settings I
don't feel the back of the front you do
one at all so that's a pretty good sign
I mean with all the effects and all the
balls going on it's actually kind of
itself
[Applause]
I am not sure
why he's at to go to the boss but you
should be able to fill this out
oh here we go
we've got in this here
so far no FPS just whatsoever is doing
is running Factory with all the possible
effects and all the mobs going on this
is absolutely beautiful
look at that oh nice
nice very nice all right so let's go
back to the cemetery and then from there
we'll see how the exploration is like
all right so the size of the phone is
pretty well suited for myself because
you know I have huge hands and this
thing when it comes to navigating the UI
it does it pretty damn well even the
menus because everything is on here you
know it's constrained by space and the
OLED just makes all the colors pop out
especially when all the effects from
your spells and everything so let's just
move on to
the ash world
[Applause]
exploration here
what the hell is that I'm not sure
all right let's move on while she
release but I'll do it never mind
oh boy I'm gonna Scoot a little bit hold
on
[Applause]
yes
even in this small capacity when it
comes to what you may call exploration
it's actually doing pretty all right I
need to get this out of the way
all right let's just kill a few more
nights and we want to find a fox and I'm
getting discovered now give you a second
[Applause]
[Music]
at the bottom over there
and yeah all right so with that let's
just do a final temperature check we are
currently at 75 Battery we started off
at 97 if I remember right and we only
down to 75 after playing four games guys
four games and let's do a temperature
check on the front and the back
not too bad actually aren't we the
highest still being gen chin but it's
still pretty all right to touch it's not
burning or anything it's not searing
let's check the back 32 down here
and at the top where the chip is at
35 wow this is actually oh okay okay
okay I see you
all right so this can handle heat pretty
well I really am quite surprised so
let's move on to our final thoughts
again I am extremely surprised by how
well the s2d3 handles thermal management
even with Genji impact which usually is
the most intensive game on the hardware
the s23 beats out some gaming phones out
there if not most the battery went down
from 97 to 75 in the hour and a half
that I've had playing games on it so you
don't have to worry about charging it up
too soon the OLED screen gives us such
wonderful colors and for the performance
I know the Snapdragon 8 Gen 2 and the
adreno 740 are working hard without
breaking a sweat there were only a few
favorite jobs that I noticed in some
games but I'm also going to chalk it up
to network stability because the s23 ran
all the games buttery smooth session up
the session back to back and I'd say
this is one of the best gaming phones
I've had the pleasure to play with thus
far if you have any questions about the
s23 leave them in the comment section
below and I'll do my best to get to them
keep up to date with us by following us
on all of our socials for the latest
news and if you like this video consider
hitting the like And subscribe button it
goes a long way and if you want to check
out more stuff from us check this out
[Music]